the walls are now officially closing in
on the imploding joe biden presidency
because as prices rise as costs surge as
you the american people continue to
suffer under this failing far-left
extreme biden-harris agenda well your
president joey's approval numbers
continue to hit one low after another
and get this according to a brand new
new york times sienna poll even the new
york times has biden's approval at a
dismal 33 percent with biden underwater
with nearly every demographic including
young voters and independents now the
paper of record itself the new york
times they now appear to be turning on
biden running yet another anti-biden
piece this weekend this article entitled
quote at 79 biden is testing the
boundaries of age and the presidency
going into great detail about how the
white house staff is in a full-fledged
panic about biden's struggles now the
piece reads quote he often shuffles when
he walks and aids worry that he's going
to trip on a wire he stumbles over words
during public events and they hold their
breath to see if he makes it to the end
without a gaff now it comes as the
president and democrats continue to play
one blame game after another let's see
first they blame the pandemic then they
blame russia russia russia and vladimir
putin and of course you always blame the
rich people and you blame big oil and
gas station owners then you blame fox
news donald trump and every republican
fighting and tweeting today quote
republicans are doing nothing but
obstructing our incredible heroic
efforts to crack down on gas price
gouging lower food prices lower health
care costs and hopefully soon lower your
prescription drug costs but the american
people they're not buying any of this
including democrats because that new
york times poll also finds a whopping 64
percent of democrats yeah they see
what's going on they want someone else
besides joe biden running in 2024.
of course that means some democrats are
finally waking up to what we have been
showing you night after night after
night we used to joke about it but it's
not funny anymore your president joe
biden is weak and frail and he is a
cognitive wreck and he continues to
suffer one bizarre blunder after another
here's biden making yet another
teleprompter flub actually reading the q
instructions you're not supposed to read
them you know say it again repeat it
yeah you're not supposed to read that
part anyway he did it and he did it out
loud and then they lied about it take a
look
it is noteworthy that the percentage of
women who registered to vote and cast a
ballot is consistently higher than the
percentage of the men who do so end of
quote repeat the line
women are not without electoral and or
political or maybe precisely not and or
or political power
repeat oh joe you're not supposed to
read the cues maybe your staff needs to
make one of those little cards again
walk into the room say hello sit down
listen attentively say goodbye walk out
but baffling gaffes appear to run in the
biden family earlier today your first
lady jill biden said
this during a latin x conference in san
antonio take a look
raul helped build this organization
with the understanding that the
diversity of this community
as distinct as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
unique is the breakfast taco imagine if
a republican said that it would be
probably breathless hysteria from the
media mob for days on end if not weeks
ask yourself with the biden white house
in this much disarray more than ever
as with the democrats more divided than
ever where did democrats go from here
ask yourself that question what is their
plan b for 2024 is it kamala harris
mayor pete elizabeth warren gavin newsom
because the more we see vice president
harris
she might have thought she was the heir
apparent it's more obvious every day
that her never-ending word salads don't
make sense it may very quickly take her
out of contention for 2024 and beyond
altogether now see if you can decipher
and understand her answer to a recent
question about the supreme court's
abortion ruling see if you can make
sense of this
i do believe that we
should have rightly believed but we
certainly believe that certain issues
are just settled
certain issues are just settled clearly
we're not no that's right and that's why
i do believe that we are living sadly in
real unsettled
times
okay i got it anyway harris's uh
failures don't stop there let me play a
small sample
of the vice president's low lights this
propensity she has to repeat words in
one sentence over and over and over
again take a look talking about the
significance of the passage of time
right the significance of the passage of
time
so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time more parents are seeing the value
of educators when they had to bring
their kids
and say we're not paying them nearly
enough
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree and
when we talk about our children i know
for this group we all believe that when
we talk about the children of the
community
they are a children of the community you
got to take this stuff seriously as
seriously as you are because you have
been forced to have to take it seriously
seriously with the passage of time and
then of course inappropriate giggling by
our giggling vice president now remember
beyond all the blunders beyond all the
word salads failed far left climate
alarmist cult and their policies there
what is that the core of biden's
failures well we have failed energy
policies failed border policies failed
foreign policy it's day 331 if you're
counting of joe biden abandoning or fell
abandoning our fellow americans in
afghanistan and the warning signs on the
biden economy could not be any louder as
the president continues to put in
america last policies and put u.s energy
security completely at risk don't forget
this all started the second joe biden
took office remember he canceled the
keystone xl pipeline but he
simultaneously gave a waiver for
vladimir putin to build the nordstream 2
pipeline giving putin more leverage over
our allies in western europe it was joe
biden who put more restrictions on
drilling
it was joe biden who continues to attack
the u.s oil and gas industry it was joe
biden who still has no solutions to make
american energy
and us energy independent like donald
trump he inherited a country that was
energy independent and get this a new
report from bloomberg says natural gas
prices have now soared over 700 percent
across europe since the start of this
year alone threatening a worldwide
recession and even more surging
inflation but does your president joe
have any answers to avoid going down the
same failed path as europe or will the
far left climate cultists continue to
set the agenda and continue to make
americans and all of us and our economy
needlessly suffer so democrats can try
and you know turn their far left climate
policy fantasies into what they think is
reality biden is well in as much control
as ever as ahead of his trip to saudi
arabia we know why he's going there he's
basically going there to get on his
knees kiss the ring and kiss the ass of
the crown prince that he called a
murderer that he said murdered jamal
khashoggi the journalist in the nation
that he called the pariah nation during
the campaign but that was during the
campaign he didn't mean it you know joe
is going to beg for more oil production
but meanwhile we've got hundreds of
years of our own supply of oil gas and
coal right here in this country why
don't we go back to being energy
independent paying two bucks a gallon
for gasoline instead of five what
exactly does joe think he's going to
accomplish here especially as leaders
around the world our allies our
adversaries alike see nothing but
weakness see his non-stop failures and
they know darn well he's not up to this
job hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else